oily skin owners you know how it is your
face is immoral everything you touch
gets oily makeup slides around here are
my top skin care and makeup tips for
oily skin it's michelle of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry phd cosmetic
chemist and shiny person i live in
australia which gets hot and humid and
i'm a youtuber who has to film in front
of very hot lights so i'm pretty
experienced at dealing with oil here's
what i found works tip one the first
thing you want to check is is your skin
actually oily oily skin is genetic but
sometimes the wrong skincare routine can
irritate your skin and that can make
oily or even dry skin leak out a whole
bunch of oil so it might look like your
skin is oily even if it's not oily skin
can also be dehydrated which means it's
lacking water even if there's too much
oil this leads to a pretty common dry
but oily situation where your skin feels
tight and dry and cracked but it's also
covered in oil a lot of people who think
they have dry skin actually have
dehydrated skin unfortunately my skin is
truly oily technically oily and normal
since my cheeks are more towards normal
and having skin that's prone to becoming
dehydrated combined with a bad skincare
routine made my oily skin even oilier so
the first thing to do if you're
frustrated with too much oil is to make
sure that you're not accidentally making
the whole situation way worse if you
want a really detailed guide to doing a
skin evaluation and a rundown of the
different skin types and conditions i've
done one in my guide to basic skin care
so let's say you've confirmed that your
skin is actually oily what can you do
tip number two wash your face gently
it's very tempting to wash with harsh
cleansers to cut through the oil and try
to dry it out
don't do this this is a trap
harsh cleansers will strip away both oil
and your natural moisturizing factor or
nmf this is a collection of chemicals
that are naturally in your skin they
hold onto water and keep your skin
hydrated they're your skin's natural
humectant moisturizer harsh surfactants
can also warp the shape of proteins in
your skin leading to loss of water again
dehydrated skin now your skin has
evolved to be very responsive to its
water content when your skin's
dehydrated it's triggered to produce
more oil to keep your skin conditioned
which means more of that whole
mirrorable situation it's a vicious
cycle so gentle cleansing is the way to
break out of this if your skin feels
tight and dry after washing you are
probably overdoing it it should feel
soft and plump and if you're used to
bone dry clean skin after washing your
face
gentle washing might actually feel like
your face isn't clean it does take some
getting used to but gentle cleansing was
the number one thing that helped me and
a lot of other people with oily skin
there are a lot of things that go into
finding a gentle cleanser but the
easiest thing to do is to avoid sodium
lauryl sulfate in the top ingredients of
your cleanser and to avoid soaps i have
listed some of the common ones here
their molecules are quite slim so they
insert themselves into your skin easily
staying there and irritating it and
related to this is tip three
try washing your face less even gentle
cleansers can cause a bit of this
dehydration then oil production effect
which is why i think it's worth trying
just cleansing with cleanser once a day
i personally cleanse properly at night
and in the morning i just splash my face
with water and pat it dry with a towel
before doing the rest of my morning
routine skincare products don't just sit
on your face in one big film that blocks
everything else from mentoring i think
we tend to think of skin like glass but
it is more like a burger bun stuff sinks
in and you can't really get everything
off without also removing a lot of the
bun or your skin's components i found
that water in the morning is enough for
me and cutting down my skin's exposure
to cleanses has helped with the oil a
lot my oil ends up coming back slower
throughout the day instead of just in
one big flood plus the uncomfortable
tight feeling and greasy dehydrated but
oily situation has died down a lot
instead of having tight skin with oil on
top which was kind of like
greasy flaky plastic that had been out
in the sun for too long the oil sort of
sinks in a bit more easily and it's more
nice and dewy rather than just greasy
and a lot of people with oily skin have
found that this works for them too i do
sometimes cleanse a second time in the
middle of the day if i've been wearing a
mask or if i want to take off my makeup
early when i do that i use bioderma
micellar water which is super gentle and
designed for sensitive skin it doesn't
use proper cleansing surfactants i've
listed a few gentle cleanses that i like
in the description but remember
everyone's skin is different so it's
important to work out what your skin
likes and it's possible that your skin
does prefer to be cleansed twice a day
but i think it's worth experimenting
with this if you haven't already tip
number four sort out your moisturizing
routine it seems to make sense that if
your skin's oily it doesn't need any
more moisturizer since it produces way
too much of its own already but again
just like the cleansing thing this can
be a trap your skin's natural oil isn't
actually that good at moisturizing there
are three main ways of moisturizing your
skin there's humectants which grab onto
water and keep it in the skin occlusive
seal the water in and emollient soften
your skin your natural sebum doesn't do
the first two very well so it just
softens your skin it doesn't actually
help with water retention if your skin
is hydrated and oily then you might not
need a moisturizer you have enough of
both water and oil but if your skin is
dehydrated and oily which is the case
for a lot of people like me
then having a hydrating moisturizer that
has humectants and occlusives can keep
your skin's water content up and that
helps it control the oil i like using
lightweight products like toners with
lots of humectants during the day and
less occlusives because they can get a
bit greasy and shiny i try to use
hydrating sunscreens i also use a
moisturizer at night sometimes i layer
an occlusive product over humectant for
extra hydration
and this has all made a massive
difference tip number five salicylic
acid is great for pores salicylic acid
commonly known as beta hydroxy acid is a
chemical exfoliant and antibacterial
skin care ingredient it gets recommended
for oily skin a lot because it dissolves
in oil so in theory it's more likely to
be able to penetrate into blackheads and
clogged pores and exfoliate inside them
which means less breakouts and
blackheads now i haven't seen any actual
studies on whether salicylic acid is
better at this than other exfoliants but
it does sound pretty reasonable i've
personally found that my pores look a
lot less noticeable when i've been
consistently using salicylic acid my
favorite is paula's choice 2 bha liquid
but there are lots of different options
and if you want to find out more about
exfoliation in general i have a free
guide that i've linked down below tip 6
is to try some oil reducing skin care
unfortunately there aren't that many
skincare ingredients that have been
found to reduce oil on your face and for
the ones where we do have some evidence
there's usually only a single study so
it isn't very reliable and they might
not actually work but if you want to try
some anyway here's the stuff with the
most evidence there's one study where a
two percent niacinamide serum reduced
the amount of oil in people's faces
niacinamide is a pretty good option
because it does a lot of other stuff as
well another study found that a plant
extract of sore palmetto in a cream
reduced oiliness some vitamin a
derivatives like retinol and tretinoin
might be able to reshape the ducts that
your sebum flows out from and that can
mean it cuts down on the oil pooling on
your face clay is also good at soaking
up oil but you do need to use it
regularly to get the benefits because it
is pretty temporary although not super
temporary usually a clay mask twice a
week works pretty well tip number seven
is to get the right translucent powder
translucent powder is one of the most
essential products in my routine for
soaking up oil these powders don't look
too obvious on your face so it's really
good if you don't like to wear obvious
makeup and you can just use this over
your sunscreen as well the ingredient
that i found works best for me is starch
so i'm always looking for starch high up
in the ingredients list for any
translucent powder i've also tried using
cornstarch from the grocery store which
actually works reasonably well
although a proper product is a lot
easier to use there are also some
powders that have clay which tends to be
pretty good at soaking up oil too one
thing you can try is commonly called the
wayne goss method where you put a layer
of powder under your foundation so it
soaks up the oil before it gets to the
surface and even before it gets to your
foundation so that means it won't slide
around as much i use a big fluffy brush
to try to concentrate the powder on my
t-zone which is the forehead and the
nose and also these bits around my nose
which tend to get shiny first tip number
eight is to try dewy makeup it has been
so ingrained into my head over the years
that matters the way to go with makeup
for oily skin
just to beat the mirror ball into
submission but i've actually found that
dewy makeup works a lot better for me
when i do get oily the contrast between
the oily and the non-oily bits isn't
quite as obvious so i look more healthy
rather than patchy i usually add
highlighter on the tops of my cheeks and
the tip of my nose and a little bit of
my forehead as well then i put starch
powder lightly on top and keep topping
up that starch powder as needed
throughout the day and that seems to
work pretty well dewy makeup is also a
bit easier to blend back in with your
fingers throughout the day and this is
related to the moisturizing tip try
hydrating your skin underneath before
you put makeup on for example you can
try a hydrating toner hydrating your
skin makes it plumper and less textured
it can smooth out fine lines and reduce
flaking and that means the pigment
doesn't have as many rope bumps on your
face that can make a bunch up there are
a lot of silicone-based makeup products
and primers that are meant to absorb oil
and fill your pores but i've actually
found that these tend to make me even
greasier they're good for about half an
hour until the oil soaks into them and
then i start looking like i'm made of
melting wax it is not a good look but
silicones do work for a lot of oily skin
people on the topic of makeup tip 9 try
using less pigmented makeup this is not
going to be possible or practical for a
lot of people but it is something to try
if you haven't already using base
products like foundation that have less
coverage basically the less pigment you
have on your skin the less stuff there
is that can move around and bunch up for
example you can try using a sheer
foundation all over and then a heavier
foundation or just concealer on the bits
that need a bit more coverage i love and
i'm currently using trini london bff
serum de-stress it's a really sheer
foundation that sort of just makes your
skin look really glowy but still natural
then after that i use my fingers to
pattern the ordinary's concealer on the
bits that i don't think i covered enough
so in total there's just less pigment on
my face which means the patchiness and
bunched up bits aren't as obvious when
it happens because we know it is going
to happen you can also try using a
product like neon's photography fluid
this has light reflecting particles that
bounce light around and sort of give the
illusion of radiance and smoothness
without actually having skin colored
pigments i found that if i use this
before foundation i don't need as much
coverage and on to my final tip tip
number 10 look into medical treatments
there are a few medical treatments that
can reduce oil production too many
androgens which are male sex hormones
can cause excess oil production so
medications that reduce them like some
oral contraceptive pills and
spironolactone can also reduce oil
production isotretinoin which is better
known as accutane will also reduce oil
most of the time these aren't really
used for treating oily skin they use for
acne but reducing oil is part of how
they work if you're interested in these
obviously speak to your doctor and see
if they're suitable for you there are
also some newer treatments that are
promising for reducing oil like botox
and some laser and light treatments but
they're pretty expensive and the
evidence behind their effectiveness just
isn't super convincing yet let me know
in the comments if there's a tip i
didn't cover if these tips worked for
you like subscribe follow me on tiktok
and instagram more videos are popping up
around me if you want to note out more
on beauty science